[Music]
Michael Porter Jr coming with some heat
[Applause]
the ridiculous clutch Michael Porter
bringing the athleticism Michael Porter
Jr with that lethal stroke a dagger from
Michael Porter Jr NBA Finals is what you
envisioned this is what I hope for man
this is what every basketball player
Hope for we're on the biggest stage in
the world you know what I mean there are
those Dog Days where you just don't know
where your life is headed what's gonna
happen next but down the road you can
look back and see all the blessings now
it was just day by day putting the work
in and hopefully it panned out over time
which it has you know I'm here in the
finals
[Applause]
coach Michael Malone we know we shoot a
shoot we have that freedom but how's he
kept you accountable on the defensive
end of the floor man he been on me since
I got drafted you know this the way he's
coached me because it's made me grow
some thick skin due to hard days to
maybe not playing a lot early on in my
career and he just saw he saw the
potential in me that's why I think when
people are hard on you it's because they
see the potential in you they know
you're not average Porter drives inside
Yorkshire back out to Murray history
[Applause]
I was lucky to be around Shaq and tinny
a great dynamic duo how is it each night
to be around Joker and Jamal Murray yeah
I mean those are my guys it's cool to
see them
um and their little dynamic they got
going on you know it was It was kind of
implemented before I even came to the
team they had been uh pretty good with
that two-man game that they got going on
so yeah that's one of the best deals we
have in this league and I'm happy to be
a part of this team with a set of great
players alongside me Joker's pulling
away
[Applause]
[Music]
game one you guys come out gangbusters
lights out you didn't shoot the ball
particularly well but you get to win
game two lackadaisical why the energy
definitely wasn't there all game we we
watched the film before coming up here
to practice and we just realized and
there was a lot of stuff that we can
clean up you know that's a really good
team over there coach by a really good
coach so you got to give them credit for
coming into a hostile environment they
got confidence right now coming off that
win in Denver so we know you got to
worry about us worry about our energy we
know that we gotta come prepared and I
think we're ready to do that
[Applause]